I'm Jason Martinez I'll be talking to
you about combining computational and
data functionality what I'm really
talking about here what we call
specialized data domain so I can make
this a little larger a little bit better
these are functions that combine the
structure of your typical data functions
like element data or country data with
the ability to specify specific
parameters so for example with
thermodynamic data there we go we can
specify substance water find a property
but we can also specify what pressure
and temperature we're looking at when we
evaluate that property and so these
functions combined both static and this
dynamically calculated data so we can
get formulas formula data or we can
calculate the magnetic field of specific
place and time on the Earth's surface
and all of this is fully integrated with
the outlying Y variable frameworks that
we have in Mathematica so you can
specify a physical quantity to look up a
formula you can say which ones you want
which ones you don't so we have a lot of
moment of inertia formulas and then you
can specify your units however you want
if you're looking kilograms or meters or
miles we're looking at like a really big
disk or something of that sort so there
are several different categories of
these functions the sort of classic
version is formula data which at the
moment contains over a thousand formulas
and which we continue to expand all the
time and which as Steven mentioned you
you soon will also be able to contribute
to and it covers a wide range of
different functionalities we have other
than interesting set that we got today
so we got web advertising in there we've
got some economics or principal interest
straight up mechanics with torque and so
forth a lot of different areas of
functionality and it's all searchable
you can just ask for a specific formula
you can even specify what you want to
have is your input parameters and it
will just quickly return what that what
that should be in terms of an input and
what the result would be we have a few
other functions in this category planks
radiation law allows you to sort of
specialized version of formula data adds
a few extra visualization techniques and
their dimensional combinations is a
function that lets you specify a number
of quantities or Y variables and figure
out what what combination of them will
give you a specific dimension like given
energy mass and time like what
combination of that gives you when that
sort of thing we have the earth sciences
fairly well covered at this point
everything from earthquakes to the
gravitational magnetic field of the
planet we have snared atmosphere data
giving us details on the overall
atmosphere centered ocean data which
gives us the thermodynamic properties of
sea water so you can specify salinities
and pressures and temperatures and get
back what the various properties would
be of cor so here we're looking at the
dissolved gases in NC water as we
increase the temperature and they become
deoxygenated support nitrous oxide
apparently and then soon we'll have
psychrometric property data this is the
thermodynamic dynamic equivalent for
moist air so calculating dew points you
and all the other sort of entropy or
sound speed type properties then we have
physics and chemistry which is probably
could use a few more few more functions
will see in the future we have stopping
power data for how matter and radiation
interact so you can specify what
particles you're interested in and what
the energies they are that they have we
also have a much larger scale it's not
don't want to spend time on that we have
much larger scale we have caused
universe model data which looks at the
entire cosmos so you can figure out how
the universe is what the composition of
it is how sighs all of that and so here
we're looking at the composition of the
universe from pretty close to the
beginning of time to today which is that
line there and then out a little bit
into the future at which point dark
energy takes over as dominating
everything at least until we hit a big
rip or whatever so I already mentioned
thermodynamic data we're also gonna have
spectral line data soon that's going to
give you access to all the data in mists
atomic spectrum database so you'll be
able to look at all the wavelengths
search for what wavelength is closest to
you know you know specify what's what
what wavelength is closest to 200
nanometers for instance now get the
element and how ionized it is and all
that sort of information as well as
energy levels will also be incorporated
into that so let's get into a couple
examples maybe if i'm quick i'll be able
to get to a third one so the first one
is what is looking at what's north so
there's a number of different ways that
you can describe north in this case
we're talking about magnetic north not
the
geographic North or the North that that
the North Pole access that access that
the planet revolves around so what what
what does your compass point to when you
take it out well for most of the plant
where you know a good approximation to
this is the geomagnetic North Pole
that's the sort of classic picture where
you view the earth as a giant bar magnet
that the field lines going out from the
South Pole down into the North Pole but
this this approximation falls apart as
you get to higher latitudes F in that
case a better approximation is what's
called the magnetic north dip pole or
simply the magnetic north pole which is
the point on the Earth's surface where
the magnetic field lines go straight
down into perpendicular to the surface
of the earth and geomagnetic Model T
lets us calculate both of those we can
even include the local local topography
the elevation in that calculation if we
want it's not particularly important at
the moment for the North Pole because
it's out over water so in geomagnetic
model data you can look back all the way
back to the beginning of the seventeenth
century to calculate your your magnetic
field and determine the North Pole so
here we have the geomagnetic North Pole
and blue creeping along the northern
edge of Greenland and in red we have the
dip Pole as it jumps around the islands
of northern Canada before heading out to
sea and it is moving pretty quickly
right now will be interesting to see
next few decades if it ends up reaching
Russia interesting thing about the dip
pulls is as opposed to the geomagnetic
poles they're not antipodal so south dip
holes actually a significant angle to
the North Pole
currently ins for the near nearing
Argentina on that that part of of
Antarctica alright so this is a little
reasoning for why we want might be
interested in this and that's the
Northwest Passage the sea ice is melting
and this is becoming a commercially
viable path for bulk carriers the
Northwest Passage has been searched for
four centuries the smash searched up and
down the west coast for it before
deciding that the Bering Strait was
really the only way you're going to do
it and in the English in the 770
eighteenth and nineteenth centuries
searched for the Northwest Passage with
a few tragedies you might see that
little grouping there at the Franklin
expedition which famously went in search
of the Northwest Passage only for them
all to disappear later explorers John
ray and Robert McClure were part of the
expedition's that went out to find the
recycling expedition and save them only
discovered that they had to come to
starvation food poisoning and possibly
cannibalism but one nice thing of that
of those that was follow-up journeys is
it helps map out the last linkages in
the Northwest Passage giving allowing
future explorers to successfully
navigate the the passage even if it took
them a few years to do it but more
recently recently being the late 1960s
has been interested in this as a
commercial route the SS Manhattan was
the first one to successfully navigate
this trip I was not financially
successful but it was proved he could be
done so this is going
goes through this is generally assumed
to be the most reasonable path path so
going north of Baffin Island through
lancaster sound and the perry channel
and then right through this little
little gap here the Prince of Wales
straight and then on to the Bering Sea
but in more recent years it's become
viable in 2013 the MS Nordic Orion made
the trip carrying 15,000 more tons of
cargo in a thousand less miles of
distance then it would have had to do if
it had gone through the Panama Canal so
this is going to be of some interest and
things get a little interesting if you
look at the compass headings in that
period so let's let's pull this back
here a little bit I'll sort of increment
through it so the red arrows are
pointing towards the geomagnetic north
so this is the sort of idealized
innocent approach and the blue arrows
point where you're at where the actual
compass readings would would head and
you can see if things will get a little
bit complicated up there there's some
distortion because of the projection
here as you can see there's a lot of
shifting of magnetic field lines
particularly in the 19th century aureus
early 19th century as it zigs through
there and will be interesting to see
where it starts pointing in the future
all right so let's go to a different
example a different field meteorology
stuff looking at thunder and lightning
and rain one point I thought we were
actually going to get rain but the
forecast I mean thunder and lightning
the forecast changed we've definitely
saw enough rain last couple days so
let's look at thunder and what the speed
of sound of that is both at the ground
level and at the base of a thunderstorm
so we have a formula in formulating the
base of a
of a cloud which it bends on the
temperature or the dry bulb temperature
and the dew point this gives us a height
to start off with so snared atmosphere
data can tell us what the typical
temperatures and pressures are at those
altitudes and we can also tell us what
the typical speeds of sound are differs
a little bit slightly ah the at ground
level versus at 700 meters but we might
want to do some fine tunings this is a
sort of standard model it's not
accounting for local weather conditions
so we can use thermodynamic data to look
at dry air so we can put in a
temperature and a pressure get a
slightly different result or we might
look even more seriously at at moist air
because most air that we're interacting
with out sort of a desert or Antarctica
is going to be have a significant amount
of moisture in it so we can put in dry
bulb temperature that's you're just sort
of typical temperature and a dew point
or we could we could have put a humidity
in there if we wanted to and get a speed
of sound so this is a fairly hot balmy
day and because the extra humidity we
get a little bit faster speed relative
humidity in this case is this is
seventy-three percent there we go
alright so that's that sounds feed and
so forth let's look at lightning why is
lightning gluten or bluish well we can
get a sense of that I that's traction by
looking at the blackbody spectrum so
planks radiation law plug in thirty
thousand Kelvin for our lightning bolt
and we can see it speaks pretty strongly
in the ultraviolet range we can take a
look at the max and mean wavelength and
we can see again they're pretty far in
the ultraviolet because of the way human
eyes work
that we're going to be us as humans are
going to see mostly violet and blue and
because way the eyes work that the blue
is going to come to dominate how we see
things but we might also be interested
in how the spectral lines are involved
because that lightning bolts going to
ionize a lot of nitrogen and oxygen so
spectral line data let's just look at
the wavelengths of all those different
ions so we're looking at neutral
nitrogen and oxygen up to four times I
am ionized we grab all those wavelengths
give them nice pretty colors and plot it
and this doesn't really tell us that
much but let's look at what the
distribution of those lines are so we
look at those those lines and plot a
histogram here we can see that they they
do tend to be clustered at the low end
of the wavelength spectrum and
particularly for oxygen it has a peak
right around in that blue range again so
again that's also going to help
contribute to the bluish color all right
I think I might actually get through
this example and do the short cover
radiation so let's do one last bit of
this part so the water content of clouds
so how much water is in a cloud so let's
let's say we're looking at a
thunderstorm understorms actually got a
lot of rain in it typical liquid water
contents of a cloud of thunderstorm is
between one and three grams per cubic
meter let's look at how much water vapor
is in there as well so in the cloud a
what the water vapors the air is fully
saturated so we can quickly get out the
humidity ratio the ratio of water in to
the water in that in a sample of air to
the weight of the air itself and we can
get density of the air and get our
density of the water vapor and then we
can start looking at how much water is
an entire column of a thunderstorm so a
square meter of thunderstorm from the
base all the way to the top at 12
kilometers we get our temperatures and
pressures at the top so we have
something to calculate with you define a
quick function here it's going to get
the temperature and pressure for a
specific height use that to get the
humidity ratios and the densities and
then get us our densities and plot them
so we can see that it starts off fairly
high drops off pretty quick until it
high latitude high altitudes there just
isn't much water vapor and that's
because of the temperature there's just
not the saturation vapor pressure is at
low temperatures is going to be very
very well we can interpolate over that
integrate and discover that we have
about 20 kilograms of of water per
square meter through the cloud we could
add the liquid water content is not
quite as accurate we'll assume two grams
on average multiply it by the height of
the cloud and add that to our total
let's compare that to the actual mass of
the air in the cloud itself we can see
that's actually a very small
contribution eret the air in a cloud is
is the major component of the cloud all
right so I'll get through a bit of the
shrink of radiation so a nice picture
here of my old colleges nuclear reactor
yeah and so what shrink of radiation is
it's the radiation that's emitted by
particle moving through a medium at
faster than the local phase velocity of
light in that medium so basically the
phase velocity starts punching up and
you get something similar to a sonic
boom but you're dealing with with white
and so there's a very well-defined
formula for calculating the strength of
radiation calculating the angle that
that radiation will come off at so here
we have the formula and the various
variables involved so let's let's have a
look at what we can learn about the
shrink of radiation so well I guess we
got to the questions part let's see so
this is I'll just do a couple quick
minutes so this is just showing the
decay chains for uranium 235 we can
extract out the decay energies I'm not
going to do it here but we can sort of
get an average 2k energy for all of the
bait all the beta emissions and then we
can quickly take that average energy
take the mass of an electron in the
index refraction and work out what the
angle that this radiation comes out as
as few other things we got in here we
can take a look through stopping power
data how water and electrons interact we
can see at low energies the major loss
of energy comes from just colliding with
the atoms but as it gets faster that
becomes less dominate just shoots right
through and most of the energy is lost
through radiative processes and we can
also calculate how far it'll probably
manage to get through as you see it
doesn't get very far at those energies
only a half centimeter or so we can also
calculate what the minimum energy is we
can sort of look at the path that this
this electron would make through the
water in terms of the shrink of
radiation that it gives off so we know
its mass we know what the index
refraction is we can figure out what the
minimum kinetic energy it is it has we
can use that and
to look at how it loses energy so we can
calculate a slowdown rate do this quick
calculation and from that we can work
out what the speed of the what the
lifetime of that path is before it drops
below the shrink off limit and stop
submitting radiation and then we can
give it a quick plot of that so we have
so now that we got that there ok yeah so
we're just looking at how it was just
energy instead of Lee through it as long
and as the angle as the energy gets
lower the angle quickly drops and I
think that's probably enough for now we
have a lot of new functionality like
this coming up you've shown spectral
line data and psychometric property data
we have a few other things that will be
coming up in the coming year or so ty
data for doing essentially similar to
how geo gravity model data works doing
providing you information on on the
tides for a particular place and time or
region non-dimensionalize which will
expand the y variable framework so that
we can calculate so you can provide an
equation and it'll non-dimensionalize
the various terms it's probably
something else i'm forgetting but oh in
the formula repository of course any
questions yes
it depends the formula day we'll do a
one-time call and then you don't need
the internet let's see psychometric
property will eat it we go back to the
easier when I have a lot list to look
outside dimensional combinations doesn't
need it Planck's law doesn't need it
earthquake data unfortunately jaws drawn
a database so it needs to do that same
thing with spectral line data do gravity
and geo model data don't need to do that
they're all self-contained ty data when
we get to get it done will be the same
life for most things standard ocean data
is all local a same thing with
atmosphere data let's see stopping the
power it is local as well so mostly most
when we can we do it as local as
possible it's only if we have to really
draw on a large database that's going to
be asked you'll need an inch and an
internet connection yes Oh what's so the
properties that are involved well
there's several things so properties
you've got your densities you also have
size the universe by various measures
you can query for if you're looking at a
star that's you know a billion
light-years away get the various distant
measures from that up running out of
time here but
yeah you also have the there's an option
that lets you change the parameters of
the universe so if you want to look at
universe that's pure matter you can you
can adjust those parameters and do that
or if you want you say let's let's move
those error bars on the latest plank
data and and look at how that changes
things that's that's all available any
other questions oh to the yeah to verify
the entry yeah right yeah ms is like i'd
say probably yeah yeah i mean you have
your natural language processing for
just putting them in you could
definitely use things like unit convert
to just look at the unit's themselves
say okay what what is this in terms of
some unit that i have some sense of you
could probably use the natural language
processing to also look at it in terms
of things that you know like the you
know the size of Jupiter in Earth's or
something of that sort so that might
help be
yeah well I mean in yeah but you can
call you can yeah but you could write
yeah yeah yeah yeah yes I'm sort of yeah
sometimes some sort of thing that just
shows you like the pods that we have in
wolfram alpha where it shows you this is
you know two times the size of Earth or
you know population of France or
whatever so something like that some
sort of function that just sort of gives
you a rough equivalents that might be no
please yeah exactly exactly that might
be a good good addition I agree is that
it ours right or is everyone want lunch
i'll be at lunch too so if there's no
further questions oh yes we should all
be using metric all right well thank you
everybody
[Applause]